[Music]
every year about a half a dozen
hurricanes reach the United States with
effects ranging from heavy winds and
some flooding to the decimation of
communities destroying homes and taking
lives instead of bracing for impact with
our sandbags and survival kits
what if hurricanes never hit land at all
what if we could stop these hurricanes
by New Kingdom how would we do it could
this cause a nuclear apocalypse or would
a bomb even stop a hurricane this is
what in and here's what would happen if
we nuked a hurricane but first what
exactly are hurricanes well they're
massive storms that form over warm ocean
water near the equator hurricanes are
tropical storms the water they form over
needs to be above 26 degrees for them to
work this warm water creates humid air
which then gets thrust upwards by
tropical winds to create storm clouds
lighter winds outside the clouds steer
them and help them grow this cycle keeps
happening until the storm has winds of
at least 119 km/h at that point it's
called a hurricane they're usually about
160 kilometres in diameter and can be
nearly as large as the state of Texas oh
yeah and did we mention that these
things can last for days you definitely
don't want this coming to your home so
let's nuke it believe it or not the idea
of nuking hurricanes isn't new it's been
proposed for decades dating back to the
1950s the idea works like this a
submarine would travel underwater to
below the eye of the storm
once there the sub would launch the
nuclear bomb creating an explosion
intended to blast out all the hot air
and bring in cold air which is denser
the cold air would slow down the wind
then stop the hakka okay we have our
nuke and are ready to launch it there it
goes and well nothing happened the
hurricane is still there that can't be
good
the reason nothing would happen is
because of the amount of energy a
hurricane produces according to the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration the heat released from a
hurricane is equal to a 10 Megaton
nuclear bomb exploding every 20 minutes
in 1990 all of humanity used 20% less
energy than a single hurricane produces
so the average bombs of today would
hardly make a dent on a hurricane not
only that the hurricane would carry all
that radiation Kiton IAM and other
civilization destroying materials from
the air down to the land as if a regular
hurricane wasn't bad enough we'd now
have a radioactive one as it moved
across America it would destroy cities
with its wind and water while also
dumping radiation on earth okay let's
try this again
this time we'll use an even bigger bomb
and we mean really big
to have enough energy and force to stop
a hurricane you'd need more than 100
atomic bombs but to keep it simple let's
pack all that power into one giant bomb
if we released such a massive bomb it
would surely stop the most epic of
hurricanes but once the dust settles
you'd quickly realize that you destroyed
most of the earth in the process
so whichever way you attempted nuking a
hurricane is not a good idea
and unfortunately the number of
hurricanes continues to increase
researchers say that the warming of the
oceans due to climate change
is the reason why hurricanes are getting
stronger and more frequent and no we
can't nuke that problem either so fine
nuclear hurricane isn't a good idea did
you know that in addition to hurricanes
people have talked about nuking
asteroids and oil spills to stop them
from spreading man let's lift humans and
nuking stuff let's save those stories
for another what if